on se rend à paris ce soir avec nos
genres habib pdg du gestionnaire
d'actifs natixis investment managers
monsieur labit bon soir françois fillon
on vous a reçu le 27 février dernier sur
ce plateau on se demandait combien de
temps allait durer la crise à ce moment
là là on parle aujourd'hui de plus en
plus de plans de réouverture de
déconfinement est ce que ça vient trop
vite
à votre avis t je ne suis pas je me
prononcerai pas sur la science des
gouvernements évidemment prendre prendre
prennent en compte les avis des experts
moi ce que je dis simplement c'est que
en ce qui concerne l'économie
aujourd'hui les marchés les marchés
semblent anticiper ce retour à une
normalisation qui prendront quand même
un certain temps on est dans une période
où je pense qu'on anticipe peut-être
même un peu vite
ce rebond souvenait comme à février
j'avais on avait évoqué le fait qu on
était peut-être même pas du tout dès
cette époque là envie shepard était
peut-être plus une remontée en u
moi je pense aujourd'hui que comme le
déconfinement se fera de façon graduelle
va heroes suivant les géographies
varieront suivant les secteurs
ce sera un processus qui sera étalé dans
le temps et non par conséquent difficile
d'anticiper ce rebond avec certains
espèrent est donc un us à veut dire que
ça va être plus long mais ça s'appelle
quand même une reprise économique
une remontée économique oui mais je
pense qu'il faut pas se leurrer réouvrir
repartir ça ne veut pas nécessairement
dire revenir à l'état d' de fait avant
aussi relancer la production
ça n'est pas nécessairement dire
relancer la demande et vous savez qu'on
a les économies notamment dans les pays
plus matures que sont l'europe et
l'amérique du nord ont les économies
très fondée sur la consommation
le comportement des consommateurs sera
important est aujourd'hui difficile de
tirer des leçons de ce qui se passe en
existe encore trop tôt donc moi je pense
qu'il faut être mesuré et là le retour à
une activité économique soutenue prendra
un certain qu est-ce qui vous marque
ce moment qu'est ce qui vous marquent
depuis le début de la crise écoutez je
pense qu'il ya deux trois trucs qu'il
faut noter on a eu qu'on l'avait
anticipé d'ailleurs quand on s'était
parlé à fin février un programme de
stimulus des banques centrales sans
aucun égales par ailleurs dans le passé
donc très très très très très avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'impact sur l'être
notamment la liquidité et la
valorisation des actifs
deuxièmement des gouvernements qui se
sont impliqués de façon conséquente avec
des programmes -type aux entreprises de
façon importante mois cet élément là est
un élément important au sujet aussi pour
juger de l'impact de la crise et se
côtoient l'attention pour nous est ce
que ces programmes vont permettre
d'éviter des failles et en conséquence
des failles et apporte entiers de
l'économie
et ça c'est un point d'attention pour
nous dire est que le troisième cru qu'il
qui me frappe un peu c'est que je trouve
qu'on essaie de d'assimiler beaucoup
c'est la situation d'aujourd'hui à des
crises qu'on a connu dans le passé selon
utiliser mon beaucoup le mot récession
le mot récession c'est un phénomène
cyclique souvent le résultat de de
surcapacité d'une surchauffe de
l'économie ou des politiques monétaires
fiscales étaient inadaptées ici on a
volontairement arrêté notre machine
économique
donc on emploie un vocabulaire qui nous
semblent mal adaptés à la situation
qu'on a aujourd'hui et qui nous fait
même pas fait une dépression en créant
même une dépression est ce que vous êtes
danseur dans ce type de réflexion non
parce que je pense que les programmes de
stimulus qu'on a actuellement vont
soutenir d'une façon un minimum la
demande
l'appareil de production pour le moment
il n'est pas affecté durablement
il ya certaines entreprises sans
précédent et on pense souvent à
l'hôtellerie et à la restauration et aux
transports qui vont souffrir mais
programme de soutien sont conséquents
donc moi je ne pense pas qu'on doive
reparler de dépression même que pareils
est pas quelqu'un si on se projette dans
l'avenir à deux ou trois ans il y aura
des gagnants et des perdants de cette
cette situation il ya des secteurs qui
ont le vent en poupe ce soit la santé
que ce soit tout le travail à distance
même les régions
ils vont pouvoir revivre je pense va
avoir un regard un regain d'activité par
rapport au centre et l'est un
commentaire que je fais général parce
que on a tous découvert que le
télétravail sur une large base est
possible et donc je pense que ça va à la
fois affecté les les méthodes de travail
mais aussi permettre aux régions lâche
pas où nous autant de la france le
canada ou que les états unis qu'on peut
travailler à distance de façon à valeur
ajoutée pour les entreprises vont le
découvrir comme investisseurs vous
réagissez comme en face à la crise
actuellement bah écoutez il faut garder
la vision sur le long terme je pense
comme je viens de vous dire qu'il y aura
des gagnants et des perdants et c'est
donc là aujourd'hui il faut être
sélectif sur les stratégies
d'investissement qu'on met en oeuvre
faut reconnaître que les taux d'intérêt
vont rester très bas pendant longtemps
donc je pense que pour les investisseurs
institutionnels notamment la recherche
de rendements dans les actifs privés va
demeurer une priorité
il y aura aussi une recherche de
solutions d'investissement qui fédère
différentes classes d'actifs
je vous dirai aussi que on a devant nous
sans doute à terme bien que personne en
parle beaucoup je pense qu'on aura sans
doute à terme un retour de l'inflation
soit parce que les taux d'intérêt
devront remonter à terme les activités
devra tenir compte certains paramètres
et on a créé un endettement conséquent
pour les entreprises et les
gouvernements
ça va créer de la pression donc moi je
pense que à terme en europe l'inflation
aussi pour réduire la valeur nominale de
cet endettement est donc si ce n'est à
terme sur des stratégies qui sont qui
sont qui qui adressent les sujets
d'inflation sera sans doute important
également
dernière question est ce que on a des
problèmes structurels dans l'économie
dans les entreprises je voyais boeing
aujourd'hui qui disait ça en prend deux
trois ans pour le trafic aérien pour
revenir à la normale et ça va nous
prendre de trois à cinq ans avant que
les dividendes
ne soient restaurées boeing c'est un cas
en particulier mais est ce que ça nous
dit quelque chose sur ce qui se passe
fondamentalement est structurellement
dans l'économie et on était de toute
façon à la fin d'un cycle qui durait
depuis plus de dix ans on en avait parlé
d'ailleurs au mois de février
donc qu'on se retrouve dans une période
où est ce que de toute façon on avait un
certain ralentissement je pense que
c'était devant nous il s'est accéléré
par la crise voire à amplifier
évidemment par les décisions compris nos
gouvernements cela était à moi je veux
pas spéculer
parce que je pense qu'on est dans une
période totalement inédite on n'a jamais
vécu ce genre de situation ce genre
d'événement donc je me vois mal prédire
on est à trois ou cinq ans d'une reprise
dans différents secteurs ou autre c'est
c'est ça va être très discriminant
secteur par secteur
il ya des secteurs qui seront gagnants
faut pas se leurrer il ya des secteurs
qui seront perdants faut pas se leurrer
non plus et en tant qu'investisseur
s'étaient positionnés sur l'épaule
allocation d'actifs soleil tape on fait
notre travail aussi de soutiens
d'économies dont on est dans le marché
on a pas on n'est pas sortis du marché
parce que je pense que c'est important
aussi en tant que gestionnaire d'actifs
de d'être au soutien des entreprises
dans lesquels on investit et c'est notre
souhait merci beaucoup jean raby merci à
vous